The Joe Rogan experience from is taking
the adderall,
but uh,
the dropoff at the end of the day was
too much for him.
It was really starting to drive him
crazy because he would feel great
throughout the day and be very
productive.
And then he'd have this big dropoff
that's when you start your drinking
cocktail hour.
I'm not saying there's anything wrong
with adderall,
but I am saying a lot of people that are
getting a lot of shit done or taken
adderall,
just clean out,
clean out my closets,
which I have never done in my whole
fucking life because I can't focus to do
that,
you know.
But like I said,
fuck it.
I'm
fucking closet.
I'm have shit in there from 25 fucking
years that I was afraid to throw out.
I counted.
I had something like 1700 black plain
black shirts.
Wow.
Fuck.
I go.
How did you count those all I would have
gave up after the first couple of
hundred because I was gay donating them.
Wow.
That's incredible.
So,
um,
I'm not going to do that again.
That's when I,
that was pre adderall behavior.
That was pre adderall.
Adderall made me see,
oh shit,
I had enough fucking black tee shirts.
So adderall give you clarity
on that because my kids are trying to
get me off at
my fucking kids like that.
I put through Rehab now they're giving
me shit about my fucking adderall.
Tell me.
It's like,
no,
it's not like I've never done math
except for,
you know,
two times I was married to Tom Arnold.
But aside from that,
I've never,
I would never get into math.
I don't think it's nothing like
adderall.
I think they've got it down to where
it's very effective for a lot of people.
I'll tell you one thing,
it's real effective because I got the
back and forth of everything.
Two way mirror thing going on all the
time.
It made me.
I used to bite my nails so bad,
you know,
like a down to nothing because my dad,
he did it too.
And uh,
and uh,
but I quit for a long time.
Then I went on adderall and um,
I started biting my nails and then I had
to keep it down to only two nails that I
could buy.
I allow myself to bite only tune,
but it perfected my fucking nail biting
too,
because there's like no nail left at all
and all so good at it now.
But you give yourself two nails.
Do you have specific nails?
Yeah,
these two are my binders.
So adderall let you save your other
eight fingers essentially,
but it kind of forced me to do these to
them.
So it's got its good and bad,
but I have clean closets and you know
what else I
learned it from to write scripts.
I was able to find a fucking focus.
Yeah,
I think there's a lot of things going
on.
There's a lot of things going on in this
life and um,
I think we should acknowledge all of
them.
You know,
we should acknowledge the,
most importantly,
the mystery of it all.
That's one of the big things that drives
me crazy about someone when they say,
you know,
that this is this and that.
Is that in the,
you know,
the way you should live is this and the
way the government should do is that and
the way we're going to solve this is by
that like maybe not.
Maybe not like are you,
are you really so sure that you're
paying attention to what the fuck is
going on?
We're flying through space like we're in
a spaceship spaceship was 100 feet wide.
You'd be freaking the fuck out right
now.
The only reason why you're not freaking
out,
it's because it's like thousands of
miles wide,
but it's still a spaceship.
You're on this spinning fucking thing
and at nighttime you could see the space
you're flying through and you're
spinning a thousand miles an hour in a
circle and you're floating around this
giant nuclear explosion and that's
around other bigger rocks that are
flying behind you and gas giants and
then other galaxies and other universe
and an on and on and on and you just
hurdling through it while you're worried
about what's on TV and why the walking
dead has so many commercials and why gas
is $4.
And if you imagine,
if this was the,
let's say,
put yourself in a position where this
really was a dream and you had a lucid
dream where you're aware,
is that what you would want to do with
your dream?
If you're going to sleep at night and
you were saying you would worry about
all of these inane things.
Never actually be in the present moment.
Never taken adventure,
never go on a risk,
never love because you could get hurt.
No.
If you,
if this,
if you really did treat this like a
dream,
you would do as much cool shit as
possible,
you know,
put his,
put as many good things into that dream
as you possibly could and not not be so
fucking stressed out about all this
nonsense.
You know?
And,
and I think we've been talking a lot,
it's kinda been the theme of this
podcast,
but if you actually did,
if this was a lucid dream,
you know,
you would live it in a different way.
You would live it to have some fun and
enjoy.
What can I fly?
Because all my lucid dreams I want to
fly or breathe under water.
Breathe under water is cool too.
That's a good one.
Yeah.
It would be very strange if one day it
was.
It was proven that we are really living
in some sort of self created reality.
It would be like really traumatizing for
a lot of people that have fucked it up
and be like,
this is what I made.
But it's like remember when you were in
school and like there was a project and
you had to use your hand and make a
Turkey and you put your hand down and
drew around and then everybody did their
own little Turkey painted it and then
the teacher would put them up and they
would all look at them.
Some people's Turkeys looked like dog
shit.
It looked.
I didn't know what the fuck a Turkey
looked like.
They didn't even know how to draw around
their hand.
Like everything was a disaster.
And other people that beautiful turkeys.
Well,
your life is a work of art.
Your life is like a hand Turkey that you
make in grade school.
It's.
You could do whatever you want with that
thing.
You can make it super dope.
You know you can.
You can make it so it looks really cool
if you put the effort and time into it,
if you really focus on it or you could
just half ass that motherfucker draw a
bunch of squiggly things.
Don't look anything like fingers.
Some eyeballs are floating above his
stupid fake Turkey head and everybody's
like,
what the fuck's wrong with bob?
Fantastic.
I think one of the.
One of the coolest pieces that I've
seen,
and I have to go to the bathroom,
so I don't know if you want to play,
but it's Alan.
It's called Alan Watts.
Inception is the name of the video on
Google and that's a great video.